ON IT.
YOU KNOW ALL OF THOSE PLAYERS
LOVE HIM AS WELL.
>> THERE IS LOTS OF FUN BETWEEN
THEM.
>> DARTING WITH YOU TALKING
ABOUT THE REAL ESTATE THAT YOU
FELT YOU ALL WERE TAKING UP IN
THEIR HEADS.
TELL ME WHAT YOU WERE THINKING
ABOUT WHEN YOU PUT THAT TWEET
OUT.
>> I JUST FELT LIKE IF I WON
THE CHAMPIONSHIP I WOULD TAKE
HIM OUT.
YOU KNOW THAT'S WHAT SOMEBODY
SAID MONTHS AGO.
I WOULDN'T BE CELEBRATING A
CHAMPIONIP.
I WOULDN'T BE HAPPY WITH MY
TEAMMATES BUT AS YOU SEE THEY
WON THE CHAMPIONSHIP AND
EVERYTHING WAS GREAT ON THAT
ONE.
SHOWING UP AT THE CLUB.
TALKING ABOUT THIS AND THAT.
WHEN YOU WIN, YOU CAN SAY
ANYTHING.
I LOST IT.
-- SOCIAL MEDIA -- YOU KNOW
THEY BLEW IT UP.
THOSE GUYS CAN TELL YOU EVEN
AFTER WE LOST IN THIS SERIES --
I TOLD THEM I FEEL LIKE IT'S
TIME FOR YOU ALL TO GET ANOTHER
RING.
THEY SENT THE SAME.
YOU ALL WILL BE BACK AGAIN.
IT WAS A LOT OF FUN FOR YEARS
TO COME.
WE ARE COMPETITORS AT THE END
OF THE DAY.
WE WANT TO BE THE BEST WE CAN
BE.
THAT'S WHAT COMES WITH IT.
YES.
>> YOU ARE SAYING AFTER THAT
SERIES YOU KNEW.
IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO COME AND
GET THAT.
>> FOR SURE.
SERIES, WHOEVER WAS TH OF THAT